>> Lee Ann Potter: Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Lee Ann Potter: I'm
going to need you guys
to be really loud, okay?
Because we're here to
open the Purple Stage.
My name is Lee Ann Potter.
I direct Educational Outreach
at the Library of Congress,
and it is my pleasure
to welcome you
to the 2018 National
Book Festival
and especially to
the Purple Stage.
And I'm thrilled that there
are young people as well
as younger people
in the audience,
and I would love your
help this morning
in opening the Purple Stage,
because I want everybody
in this expo hall to know
that the Purple Stage is open,
so will you please help
me yell a little bit?
>> Yeah.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Okay, so here we go.
We're going to do this.
Oh, I heard a good one.
That was good.
Okay, so give me a P.
>> P!
>> Lee Ann Potter: Give me a U.
>> U!
>> Lee Ann Potter: Give me an R.
>> R!
>> Lee Ann Potter: Give me a P.
>> P!
>> Lee Ann Potter: Give me an L.
>> L!
>> Lee Ann Potter: Give me an E.
>> E!
>> Lee Ann Potter: And
what does that spell?
>> Purple!
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yes!
The Purple Stage is
officially open, woohoo!
[ Applause ]
That was actually pretty good.
Thank you.
I was a little concerned.
It was a little quiet.
That was nice.
Now it is my pleasure to
welcome our first speaker
to the Purple Stage.
Matthew Cordell is both an
author and an illustrator.
He wrote Trouble Gum,
Another Brother, Hello!
Hello!, and one of
my favorites, Wish.
Do you guys know that story?
I love seeing nods.
That's that story
with elephants,
and there's fabulous confetti.
Okay, there's a line
in that book that goes
"Before we were ready
for you or waited for you
or made plans for you.
Even before we knew we wanted
you, we wished for you."
And while the story is about
parents wishing for children,
it actually to applies to those
of us who work at the Library
of Congress, and we wish
for a day like today,
and we wish for all of you to
be here at the Book Festival.
So, thank you and thank
you for writing that book.
Matthew has also illustrated
the books of such renown authors
as Philip Stead, Rachel
Vail, and Gail Carson Levine.
He lives outside of Chicago
with his wife, the novelist,
Julie Halpern, and
their two children.
He is also the 2018 Caldecott
award-winning author of Wolf
in the Snow published
by Feiwel & Friends,
and he is with us
today to read it.
By the way, the Caldecott
medal was named in honor
of 19th century English
illustrator Randolph Caldecott.
It is awarded annually by the
Association for Library Service
to Children, a division of the
American Library Association
to the artist of the most
distinguished American picture
book for children.
It is a huge honor.
After Matthew's reading,
assuming time allows--
which we think it will-- he
will take your questions,
and he will be signing
books from 10:30 to 11:30
in signing line number 15.
Welcome Matthew.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for doing this.
>> Matthew Cordell:
Thank you [inaudible]?
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah.
[Inaudible] because
it's that one.
>> Matthew Cordell: This one?
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah.
>> Matthew Cordell: Okay.
Okay, good morning.
Thank you for all for waking
up early and being here
for the first presentation.
I was a little worried.
So, my name's Matthew Cordell,
and I want to tell you a
little bit about myself,
and then I'm going to read
Wolf in the Snow to you guys.
I always like to start out when
I'm speaking to boys and girls.
Raise your hand.
Who likes to write stories?
Yeah, grownups can raise their
hands as well [laughter].
That's good.
Okay. Raise your hand
if you like to draw.
Who likes to draw?
Okay, good.
Those are my favorite
things to do.
I grew up drawing,
and, sort of later
in life, I started to write.
So, I'm going to tell you
a bit about how I do that,
how those writing and
drawing becomes a book.
Oh, that's just the
first slide there.
So, I live in Chicago area now.
Is anybody from Chicago
by any chance?
No? Okay, no one?
[Laughter] But I grew
up in South Carolina.
Is anybody from South Carolina?
It's a little closer.
Yeah? So, I grew up
in South Carolina.
And then, you know, growing
up in South Carolina,
the thing about me is
I always loved to draw.
As soon as I could, you know,
put a pencil on a piece of paper
and make pictures, I just
loved to sit down and draw.
That's always been the constant
thing in my life is drawing.
But now I live in
Gurnee, Illinois.
Has anybody been to
Gurnee, Illinois?
[Laughter] You have?
Wow. Okay.
After college, I moved to
Chicago, and I lived there
for about six or seven years.
I was about 24 when
I moved there.
And then I got married.
My wife and I moved
to a little--
It's a suburb of Chicago.
It's about an hour
north of Chicago.
It's called Gurnee.
We're famous for having a Six
Flags Great America in our town.
And my wife and I,
we have two children.
This is our daughter Romy.
And, Romy, she's 9 years old.
She's going into fourth grade.
Any fourth graders
in the audience?
Not a single fourth grader ?
[Laughter] Does anybody
like Star Wars?
Any Star Wars fans?
Okay, good.
So, Romy was dressed as
a Star Wars character.
Raise your hand if you know
what Romy's dressed as.
Who's Romy dressed as?
Rey. Yes, Rey from Star Wars.
So, I'm a big Star Wars fan.
I grew up loving Star Wars, and
I've sort of forced my children
into liking Star Wars.
We were going to a
comic book convention.
I don't know if you've
ever been to one of those,
but you get to dress up
in interesting costumes
at a comic convention.
So, Romy was dressed as Ray from
Star Wars, and our son, Dean,
who's 5 years old,
he was dressed up.
And that's what he was
dressed as [laughter].
Who's Dean dressed as,
any Star Wars fans?
Who's Dean dressed?
BB-8, yes, Ray's little
droid sidekick, BB-8.
Okay, so now I'd like to talk
you a bit about where I work
and the things I do
when I'm working.
Oh, one more picture of
a [laughs] family member.
Sorry [laughter].
This is our cat Norbert
[laughter].
Named after a dragon from
Harry Potter my daughter
named Norbert.
So, this is where
I work right here.
Isn't that a very nice looking
place to work [laughter]?
This is my studio.
And it's in the basement
of our house.
So, I actually like
to work from home.
I can just get up and
go downstairs and work
without having to get in a car.
And so, you know, does that
studio look clean to you?
>> No.
>> Matthew Cordell: No,
it looks a little messy.
Now, whenever I go around
speaking to boys and girls
at schools and at festivals,
I like to show them pictures
of my studio in its
sort of natural state,
and it gets pretty
messy while I'm working.
And a lot of that mess,
it's not like gross mess,
like food or dirty laundry.
It's mess related to the
books that I'm making.
So, there's sketches
and drawings
and different books
laying around.
So, I like to show boys
and girls, you know,
a space isn't always going
to be clean while you're
really busy working.
And, you know, a lot of authors
and illustrators probably want
to explain how organized
and clean they are.
But I like to show
them my studio sort
of in its very active state.
So, just a couple other places.
This is where I draw
my pictures.
And I'm going to show you
the types of tools I use
in a little bit, but I do
all of my pictures sort
of the old fashioned way.
Some illustrators now do
their pictures completely
on the computer, and
they will draw right
on the tablet screen
or a computer screen.
But all my pictures are
done on paper with pens
and pencils and paints.
But I do use the
computer a little bit.
This is my computer desk.
Now, I use the computer
mostly to write stories,
but I also use the computer
when I'm talking back and forth
with the publishers of the
book and the publishers
of the companies that print and
send the books out to bookstores
and libraries everywhere.
So, use the computer
every day for that.
These are some of the picture
books I've done over the years.
Now, some of these books here,
the ones on the top two rows
there, except for Trouble Gum,
those were books that were
written by another author,
and I was asked by a publisher
to illustrate their book.
But the other books you see on
the bottom row, those were books
that I wrote the story
and illustrated myself.
So, I do a little bit of both
when it comes to picture books.
And I also occasionally
illustrate chapter books.
I've never written a
novel or a chapter book,
but occasionally I get
asked by a publisher
to illustrate the cover
and the inside pictures,
which are usually smaller
and in black and white.
And the last type of book I
illustrate is a poetry book.
Boys and girls, you
reading any poetry?
A few of you, yeah?
Okay, poetry doesn't get enough
action, I feel like, these days.
So, I really love poetry.
I don't write poetry, but I do
get asked to illustrate, again,
other people's novels
written in poems
or different collections
of poems.
So, that's the last type
of book I illustrate.
So, now I want to read to
you Wolf in the Snow, but,
before I do that, I want to
just tell you a little bit--
And we heard a little
bit in my introduction--
about I won the Caldecott medal.
Have you guys heard of the
Caldecott medal before?
Raise your hand if you've
heard of the Caldecott medal.
Okay, good.
Occasionally, I'll go to a
school and there'll be no hands
that go up, [laughs] which
is a little, a little bad.
But, okay, so there should
have been some text on here.
But anyway [laughs].
I don't know why it's not there.
So, the Caldecott medal,
it means it's the best
illustrated American picture
book within that year.
So, I won the Caldecott
medal for 2018.
It was named after a
British illustrator many,
many years ago, but the irony
sort of is that you have
to be an American citizen
to win the Caldecott medal.
And the other thing
is that, I think,
the very first Caldecott
medal was given
out in 1938, I believe it was.
So, in all those years
and all the books
that have been published,
only like 70 something books
have won a Caldecott medal.
So, it's really,
really special thing.
It was really exciting to
find out sort of a thing
that a picture-book
illustrator dreams that's going
to happen to them.
So, it's been a really
exciting year for me.
These are some Caldecott-winning
books
in case you're not
familiar with the Caldecott.
You've probably seen
at least one or two
of these books in your life.
That one on the bottom right,
Sylvester and the Magic Pebble.
That's my favorite
Caldecott-winning book
by William Steig.
And these are the types
of pens that I use.
I use pens that you dip
into a bottle of ink.
They don't have ink inside them.
They're kind of old-fashioned
type of pens.
And I do paint the
pictures in watercolor.
These are my brushes.
Okay, so now I'm going to read
the book Wolf in the Snow.
And it's a wordless book.
Have you guys ever
read a wordless book?
>> Yay.
>> Matthew Cordell: Okay, good.
Yay [laughs], I get
a little cheer.
Okay, so there's no text.
The pictures tell the story.
So, this is the first
picture we see.
We see a girl in her
home with her family.
It's snowing outside.
And the girl, she's walking
away from home first thing
in the morning, saying
goodbye to her dog there.
And we see the girl on this one
page, she's walking somewhere,
and we see the-- What do we
see on the other page, there?
We see wolves, yeah.
So, we see a pack or
a family of wolves.
Turn the page.
Now we see the title
page Wolf in the Snow.
And now we see the girl.
She's leaving school.
So, she was at school.
She had gone to school.
She's leaving school
for the day.
More snow is seeming to fall
as we keep turning the pages.
We turn the page again,
and what do we see again?
>> Wolves.
>> Matthew Cordell: We
see the wolves again.
And there walking through the
snow you can see the breath
that you see.
You can see your breath
when it's really cold out.
More snow is falling.
So, now the girl's
really fighting her way
against this wind and the snow.
The storm is really
starting to pick up.
And the wolves are fighting
now against this wind and snow.
And what's happening to that
little wolf pup down there?
[Inaudible] It's falling behind.
It's getting left behind
by the adult wolves--
the noise or the
confusion of the storm.
So, now, the girl,
she's fighting her way.
She's trying to get
towards these trees maybe
to get under some trees.
And then we see the wolf
pup is fighting its way
to get towards those trees.
And now, for the first
time, we see the girl
and the pup in the same space.
Now, if you ever encountered
an animal in the wild,
even if it's a baby or a small
animal, you have to be careful
with any wild animal,
because they're unpredictable.
They're not like our
dogs and cats at home.
We don't know how
they're going to react
to people that they don't know.
But this girl, she sees this
pup is down on the ground.
It's in a submissive state
like that, and it's whining.
So, she reaches down for the
pup to see if she might be able
to help it, and she
puts it in the snow.
And what happens as it tries
to walk across the snow?
It sinks. Yeah, it
sinks in the snow.
So, it can walk across the
snow, but it can't get very far
without getting stuck.
So, she picks it up, and
the little pup howls.
And then somewhere way
across the landscape,
across the distance, she
hears another wolf howling.
So, she has to decide.
She could take this pup to these
other wolves that she hears
out there, which could
be kind of scary.
Or she could leave the
pup here and she could try
to find her own way home.
But if she left the
pup and just went home,
I don't think it would
be a very good book,
wouldn't be very
interesting [laughter].
So, she's going to save the pup.
She's going to walk, and find,
and try to reunite this pup
with these adult wolves.
So, she's walking.
She going to follow the howling.
And as she's doing that, she has
to brave all these other
elements of nature.
She has to, you know, climb
up and down high hills of snow
and cross frozen streams.
She encounters other
more aggressive animals
like this angry raccoon there
and, you know, screeching owls,
scary sounds in the forest.
And what's happening
as she keeps walking,
what's happening
with the howling?
The howling's getting
bigger and louder.
So, now she's climbing up that
hill, and it's bigger and louder
than ever that howling.
And now for the first
time we see she finds one
of these big adult wolves.
Now, adult wolves
are very big animals.
They're much bigger than,
like, an average dog.
So, just the size of a wolf
in the wild could be
a very intimidating,
very frightening thing.
And we see the girl.
And she doesn't know how
the wolf is going to react.
And the wolf doesn't know how
the girl is going to react,
so they're just kind of
looking into each other's eyes
with this uncertainty.
So, the girl drops the pup.
And what happens when
the pup tries to cross
to see its mother wolf there?
>> It sinks.
>> Matthew Cordell:
It sinks again.
Yeah. But now the mother wolf
is able to pick up the pup,
and she can carry
it off to safety.
Now, at this point, the girl is,
at the end of this
very long day,
walking through this deep snow.
Seeing these wild
animals, she sort of falls
over to catch her breath there.
But she's got to
find her way home.
So, she gets up and walks away.
And we see in the bottom
of the picture there we see
the other wolves have returned.
And that one black
wolf is watching her.
It's maybe wondering where she's
going, and who was this girl
that brought our pup back to us?
Now, she looks out
into the night sky,
and what does she
see in the sky?
>> [Inaudible] lights.
>> Matthew Cordell: She sees
some lights, yeah, flashing.
There's some barking, so maybe
this could be her family.
Maybe it could be another family
that could help her get home.
So, she's going to
follow those lights,
but she's walking and walking.
And now she's just so
tired that she falls over.
And when she falls over here,
she's fallen into the covering
of those trees, and who's
come back now that she's?
>> The wolves.
>> Matthew Cordell: The
wolves have come back.
And in these pictures, we see
the wolves surround the girl.
And then they howl.
Why do you think they
would howl like that?
Why do you think
they would howl?
So, they could attract
attention.
Maybe they want to
help this girl
like the girl helped
their family.
So, they're howling there.
In fact, it does it.
It attracts attention.
It attracts one of the people
that's out there looking.
I mean, this could be
the mom or the dad.
In my mind, it was the mom.
And she shows up
with her flashlight.
So, the mom and the
daughter together
and it's very happy moment.
And then we see the wolves
at the top of that hill,
and they're howling in
this very happy moment.
Can you guys give me a nice big
wolf howl for this happy moment?
[ Howling ]
Wow, that's good.
Yeah. Good, good [laughs].
And now the two lights.
The two lights of the mom
and dad find each other
at the bottom of that hill.
And then the book ends just
like it began with the mom
and the dad and the daughter
together in their home again.
So, that is the end
of Wolf in the Snow.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
And just really quickly,
I was going to tell you
about my next book that comes
out at the end of the month.
This is very different book.
I like to write sort
of serious books.
I also like to write
more humorous books.
And this book was really
based on my relationship
with my daughter, Romy.
Her name is the girl
dressed in the Star Wars.
So, Romy and I, we made
a book together one day.
We just sat down and
drew and wrote a book.
It was the Wizard of Oz,
and she wrote part of it.
And so I wanted to make a book
about a dad and a daughter
who make a book, but, you
know, I wanted the daughter
to be this very headstrong,
very spirited personality
like my daughter Romy is.
So, this girl, Alice,
she likes to dress up.
She likes to take on
characters, but she wants
to be the strongest character.
And she knows that the king
is at the top of the chain
of command, so she doesn't
care about being the queen.
She wants to be the king,
and the dad's going
to be the princess.
So, this is Alice getting
dressed up in her king costume.
So, she becomes the kind,
and that's King Alice, there.
And then they proceed--
There's dad waking up.
That may or may not be
based on me [laughter].
So, dad's waking up.
What are we going to do today?
And dad's very tired.
Sees that it's snowy outside.
So, Alice says, "Can
we make cupcakes?"
And dad's remembering the
disaster that happened
when they made cupcakes.
And this is a picture of
some fun that Romy and I had
in the kitchen one day
where she dressed as a clown
and threw a pie in
my face [laughs].
So, the book was based on the
different fun kind of things
that we do together as
a dad and a daughter.
So, then she says,
"Can we play dress-up,
and can I do your makeup?"
And dad's remembering
what that was like.
And this is a picture.
Romy actually did my
makeup one day [laughter].
So, she says, "Let's
make a book."
So, they're going
to make a book.
And then they write a book.
So, really the book is sort of
day in the life of this family.
So, it's all the different
fun things they do.
You know, they watch TV, at some
point, about unicorn buddies.
And then there's a
unicorn stampede,
and she hits her
dad accidentally,
and she gets a timeout
[laughter].
But they keep making the book.
It's dinnertime and so on.
And then they read the
book at the end of the day.
So, that's King Alice, and
that comes out on September 25.
So, look for that one.
Thank you, yeah, yeah.
So, that's the end we have about
five minutes for some questions.
Does anybody have a burning
question they need to ask based
on some of the things
we talked about?
My friend over here, yes?
>> How did you [inaudible]?
>> Matthew Cordell: How did I
come up with Wolf in the Snow?
Good question.
So, Wolf in the Snow.
A lot of times when I write and
illustrate, stories are based
on something that happened
to me in real life.
So, King Alice is
based on something.
Some of my other books
were based on actual things
that I did or things
that my kids did.
Wolf in the Snow
started out as a picture.
It wasn't a story at first.
I just had this idea
for a picture,
and that picture was
a girl in a red coat.
She was standing in the snow
across from a big, black wolf.
And I didn't really know
what it was going to be.
And I didn't know much
about wolves either.
And I used to think wolves
were big, bad scary animals
that wanted to eat up humans,
eat up people, very
scary beasts.
And I learned about
wolves, and I learned
that they were not that at all.
You know, they had that bad
idea about them for many years.
But they really are
just families like us,
and they do hunt, but
they hunt other animals.
And they're pretty
much afraid of people
because of the way
people have looked at them
and treated them over the years.
So, I wanted to do a story
then about, you know, a person
and an animal who didn't
really understand each other.
But they ended up
being in a position
where they needed
to help each other.
And by doing that, they were
able to learn about each other
and become better
beings, creatures,
and people because of it.
So, that's how Wolf in
the Snow came about.
Really just by learning
about the animals.
Yeah? You have a question?
[Inaudible] I'm sorry.
What was your question?
Oh, okay. How did I draw
so good without messing up?
I love that question.
Lots of practice.
So, you know, like I said, I've
been drawing my entire life.
And so I don't always
draw so well.
Like, sometimes the
drawings are not very good,
and sometimes I have bad
days when I'm drawing.
But you just have
to keep trying.
You can't give up.
So, if there's something you
like to do, if it's drawing
or sports or whatever it is that
you love, you're probably going
to keep having those bad days,
but if you stick with that thing
that you love, that's
really a cool thing just
to watch yourself get better and
better every year that goes by.
So, for me, that thing
was always drawing.
So, lots of practice, lots
of good and bad drawing.
But, you know, just
being satisfied
with the good drawings
when they happen.
Somebody else?
Yes? Question?
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
He said, "Why do I dip my
pens in ink instead of using
that pens that have
ink in them?"
So, the pens that I use, they
have these special tips on them.
They're called nibs.
And that nib is like a little
metal point, and it opens
up when you push down on it.
So, you can get lots of
different thicknesses
of your line when
you're drawing.
And so it makes the drawing
more interesting to me.
If I was drawing with, like,
a pen, you know, a typical pen
that has ink in it like
this with a very fine tip,
your lines usually
are pretty straight--
Not straight, but
they're pretty consistent.
They're pretty much the
same as you draw with them.
But I like for my lines
to be kind of scratchy,
and they get thick at
times and thin at times.
That's why I use
that special pen.
You have to dip it in the
ink which is kind of a pain,
but it makes it look a lot
better to me, personally.
Somebody else?
Anybody over here
have a question?
Okay, right here.
Yes? What do I do
when I get stuck?
Yeah, good question.
I get stuck a lot, you know?
And the best thing that I
can do is just walk away
from whatever it is and
even just going for a walk,
and just getting away from it,
and getting some perspective,
and thinking about other
things, and sometimes
that helps clear your head.
So, when you come back to
it, you see it differently,
and you can look
at it differently
and problem-solve it better
instead of just sticking
on that one thing that you're
really fighting to make work.
So, I see we have one minute.
Any grownups have any questions?
Grownups have to use
the microphone [laughs].
Or you can just shout it out.
We have a minute [laughs].
>> How did you celebrate
[inaudible]?
>> Matthew Cordell:
Someone up here,
how did I celebrate
the Caldecott?
I went to Dunkin'
Donuts [laughter]
and got some donuts
with my daughter.
That was the very
first thing we did.
Then we went to Disney World,
and then we went to New York
and saw the SpongeBob
Musical [laughter].
One more question.
>> Do you always work
in pen and watercolor,
or do you ever use
other mediums?
>> Matthew Cordell: I
pretty much only work in pen
and ink and watercolor.
I'm really comfortable
with that,
and I feel like I'm still
learning in some ways,
so I feel like I'm just
constantly evolving my process.
Occasionally, I will
color something.
I've colored a couple
books in Photoshop
with sort of flat colors.
But to me, my most gratifying
way of working is in pen
and ink and watercolor.
So, I'm seeing now I
have to wrap it up.
So, one more round of applause
for me, please [laughs].
All right, okay.
Thank you so much.
Been a real pleasure.
Thank you.